the countdown is on to Nick Jonas and
Priyanka Chopra's wedding it's this
weekend and the Hollywood stars are
getting the Royal Treatment over in
Indiana this is crazy and why not
Priyanka is a princess in my and Nick's
everything we know about their big day
Nick and Priyanka landed this morning in
Jodhpur India just ahead of their
three-day wedding extravaganza and they
were mobbed by the paparazzi the glam
couples stopped a pose that they arrived
at their hotel also traveling with them
Nick's parents Briana's mom Joe Jonas
and his fiance sophie Turner and Kevin
Jonas and his wife Danielle Jonas all
this as Priyanka reveals wedding secrets
to Vogue
the actress tells the magazine they will
have two wedding ceremonies a
traditional Indian wedding and a
Christian service they will be held in
different spots at this spectacular
Palace Priyanka will wear Ralph Lauren
during the weekend and Nick well we love
this he's set to ride in on a horse
holding a sword meanwhile check out
these fireworks laid out in a field
ahead of the I Do's Priyanka says quote
people will need vacations after this
wedding asked for Priyanka is long time
pal Megan Markel et has learned that she
and Harry won't be flying to India for
the nuptials a source tells us quote
Megan isn't traveling much as she is
pregnant Priyanka who posed in a red
velocity hug address for the magazine's
January 2019 issue also dished about her
whirlwind romance with Nick she faced
including how he introduced himself to
her at last year's Vanity Fair Oscar
party he says and I put my drink down
get on one knee this is in front of a
bunch of people and I say you're real
where have you been all my life like
loud so this is really like the Royal
Wedding of Indian that would make Nick
the Megan oh he mark old his life yes he
did
Bravo
[Music]